today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death mountain water
murder your thirst today's guest is um
i mean the dude is just a real
you know he's gone the road most
traveled and then
the road he wanted to travel um
we're gonna learn you know i don't know
if we're gonna learn [ __ ] but we're
gonna do our best man
i'm just honored to be here here with
him today i actually met him 20 years
ago
but neither one of us really remembers
it but um but we'll get into it
ladies and gentlemen mr jim
[Music]
and brewer you my stories
[Applause]
i once you realize the point of you're
not in it for the rest of the world
you're in it for you and for what you
want to put out there
i don't care what this one says
what movie they'll put i don't care yeah
it's this is
you can't get a better life than what
you're doing right now yeah you can't
you you beat the system yeah that is
uh there's no
better thing in life you control your
destiny yeah i think i feel sometimes
are we rolling
i think i feel sometimes like there's
always this thing like
like if you don't there's like a
validation this like this is this
invisible validation
you know i'm talking about that
conversation yeah i know all that it's
this hollywood thing it's like oh if i
don't
you know i could have i could be selling
tickets but if i'm not on the tonight
show man i'm a no
you know there's no i don't have that i
haven't been licked by the goose or
something you know
of course so i start i started out i
wanted to be accepted by
by this guy and this guy and this
comedian because all comedians are like
unless you're accepted by
this guy or that guy right and um
you're not in i'm not in and and to be
honest with you i didn't like any of
them
because i didn't like any of them they
were
i i grew up uh very very
family oriented morals grounded
when i grew up it was god family
friends everyone looks after each other
this industry is i'll slice slice your
throat
i'll dance in your blood and then
videotape it and make money off
yeah and and it's uh
it's traumatizing is the best word to
use it and
uh i i went through i went through a lot
uh through the whole coming up the whole
system i learned so much
i'm glad what i learned you know
sometimes i'll reflect on
i talk a lot about uh you're talking
about things
god is so sad i don't even know where to
start so yeah no
thanks for coming in it started with the
clubs
doing the city clubs and the city
in new york city and uh you know
it was it was uh i can i knew there was
envy
and and people were jealous and like
what am i doing to bother you what am i
doing to bother you right
i'm doing my set and this is bothering
you bothering you that they're laughing
what is going on so uh as as time went
on at
hollywood i realized it
is it was the most vile
it's soulless yeah right there's yeah
you look for this
you look to think at some point this
thing has to have a heart
or some compassion and there's and it
never
turns that and if anything it's it
lures you in and going no i'm here for
you
i'm gonna give you some honesty and
compassion and then when you're not
looking
at it
it's uh yeah it's pretty it's
uh it'll make so shady it doesn't even
it's i know you don't make [ __ ]
sashimi
traumatizing is a good word man like i
have uh
i have a friend who just got in trouble
he was using a they caught him that he
was using a racial slur and
and it's crazy like they uh
so our news outlets this was fascinating
to me
news outlets that never would have even
paid attention to him before
are now like put like just using the
term racial slur in their headlines
right
so basically they're using
his mess up you know his mistake to just
to get
their clicks and it's like yeah it's
just because
they're in the way they're using the
word now
like they're using the racial you know
what i'm saying they're then using it
and i don't understand what that is or
where it comes from but i consider
all them bottom feeders yeah they're
complete bottom feeders
and but there's people there's
real humans that are attached to the
that are in the tank you know
they're in the tank their days are
coming yeah you can't live
forever with with with trying to do that
to people
did you um so was there a point where
you kind of felt like okay i'm going to
take myself
out of this some or i'm going to slow
this train
down like i just remembered just from an
outsider perspective i just remember
dang that's jim brewer man he's one of
the funniest guys that there is and he's
a star like i didn't
i never noticed that you like separated
yourself from
like some of the vibe or the industry or
something did did you feel like you kind
of did that oh i know i did
it was uh first it was the
what once you know i kind of got i won't
say
shot out of a i had to drive i was
confident i was cocky so
in 89 i decided
this is what i'm doing forever right and
i was the
i was doing clubs and was out of florida
were you doing well then
yeah and i had goals i was like i'm
gonna become house emc
to the middle and then when i'm middle
i'm gonna make your life miserable
yeah trying to follow that it was fun
and i loved that oh being in the middle
was [ __ ] good you get off to
22 minutes you're a [ __ ] legend
crushing it
and then they're like we want to flop
you not not for the same pay you're not
yeah
so i went through that stage we're going
to like follow the kid
yeah oh yeah there's always that guy
dude yeah and then you meet
and then you come across some people
that that school you
yeah oh you don't you think i've never
seen someone like you before
guy you know what i'll go up before you
ping ping pong bang
follow that kid oh wow okay yeah maybe
we shouldn't
flip-flop yeah and then um once
tv started uh
i was actually on a an old black show
called the uptown comedy club that was
my first
big it wasn't huge but it was that was
a weekly show it was syndicated uptown
comedy club was it so was it sketches
and stuff
yeah no when i say was it awesome
you know what it was it was it was the
best
television show i've ever been on my
life
and why i say that because there were no
egos
uh everyone was everyone was helping
each other
i i've and i thought this was
i thought this was the industry and not
only that
they would they would talk to us like
the producers were sitting it was in
harlem
yeah it was 125th and 5th in 89
uh no this is 92 damn that must have
been
that was such a hype time too there was
so much like
i'm sure especially in harlem there was
like just a lot of fun energy in the air
oh my god and it was it was it was a
tough area oh yeah
i saw someone get a shot yeah that's
awesome dude
tracy morgan was on that show and i'll
never forget
it it taught me about
uh the hood yeah and
and a different side of of what you st
it's just a completely different side of
life that i
that no college could ever teach you
there's no teaching
teacher when i'll never forget what
happened was i heard
right and tracy morgan goes who got shot
and i went oh you heard the fireworks he
was uh i wouldn't fire him so we got
shot
but he said it as as
calmly yes yeah and then he went oh he's
across the street
oh he's struggling and i still thought
he was kidding
like he's play-by-play like he's out
michael suddenly yeah and
look at this guy i can't even get
another yard yeah like oh
he might get another brow he's down he's
on the ground he's flattened out
oh he's trying to get back up he's up to
his oh he's down again are these oh he's
out of bounds man
when it comes to being alive this guy's
out of basket oh and here comes the
hecklers
look at you now look at there's nothing
worse of being shot
you're getting knuckles and now the
hecklers come
while you're struggling for your life
for your life oh he's leaking he leaking
he's always getting hard and i'll never
forget the one guy had no teeth he came
up i swear to god he goes
you smell that that's like you smell
smoke it smell like when i was involved
in vietnam you can still smell the smoke
oh my god and i'll never forget since
the blood is dripping
over the curb and and it's going down
the drain
yeah us and then the paramedics come
like yeah you know so two jews walk in a
bar
i got a greek joke for you bro and still
they look at you now
yeah lookie i was like what you're like
all right let's go back to rehearsing
and then a church choir shows up also
though for no reason
like it's just amazing dude
so that to go from that to
uh then the
real hollywood came and i'll tell you
what
i'll let you in on a loose sun but i'm
not gonna drop names okay
but i'll never forget the these are
black producers
uh a guy named kevin brown and andre
brown
uh and he was later on 30 rock but he
they would come to us and they would
tell us about
vanity and losing your mind in hollywood
and be careful
and they came back from hollywood to try
and expand us
and they sat us down like you ain't
gonna believe what we saw
what what did you see and they said we
saw
so and so huge name
so-and-so huge name
and so and so big name back in the day
chicken hawking at a party and i went
see you're white i said what's chicken
hawking everyone
he's white he don't know chicken i said
what is chicken hawking that's when you
uh
hanging out with boys at a transvestites
i went why
what uh see now you now you're telling
stories
now you're telling stories yeah but
i never forgot that three years later
this name
ping busted chicken hawking that one's
sick
this one bing busted yeah
huh they swept that uh that's what i
call
to me hollywood's a mafia it's a big
dark mafia yeah it is and then what
happens is
i remember one of them it was like the
mobsters come they're like we understand
not mobs is like a town right right
right whatever you're talking about
the attorneys yeah right and they come
along like listen
you sign this you do some movies there
we'll put the soul under the table we
got enough money to make this go away
paying it's gone no one ever brings it
up
no one ever brings it up with this
person that's crazy and there's two or
three of them
huge huge but
i guess what i'm saying is by time i
started doing sonic live
and i have baked blah blah and and
tv thing you know tim allen all this
chat it was
that's when i really saw how
dark and so it's just it was dark
it's i get creeped out i get scared to
death
it was soulless yeah never seen anything
it and i still every time i get out
there
i feel like oh man i just i don't feel
life out there yeah i feel it at all
you know what i know i've always said
when i get off the plane there i feel
like i'm in the office it always
like um i just feel like i'm in an
office constantly it always
every light feels like a fluorescent
light it feels like it never ends um
but it's hard to find a it is it's hard
to find a comfort out there
but there's always this dangle of a
carrot yeah and it's a carrot and i
don't even know what it is because like
it's vanity is vanity is it
you know you want this right you know
you want this
you're better than so and so you know
you're better than so and so
you get this then it'll be worth this
yeah and then you're and then your road
will be worth this
you want to be you think that person
deserves to be in arenas
or on billboards you should be on take
you want it
it's there's a lit that is oh i believe
that that's what we're saying as you're
saying it i'm thinking that i'm thinking
i'm trying to feel like you know
a lot of times things will land for me
and my feelings like is it vanity is it
yeah it's something it's ego and vanity
yeah
it's ego it's vanity i want to be better
than them
yeah it's uh yeah it's uh it's not easy
no it's not easy and i i think also you
start to see the others
like you start to see the other side of
it too where it just
there's never like an understanding you
never get to talk to the person to have
the conversation about what's
it's just there's never any real
instructions it's all kind of
vague the business is vague the money is
it's all it's all vague and there's all
extra people always stacked in at the
last minute you've never
met right and they are they're living
and they've owned your family now
they're just crazy your grandfather is
now their grandfather
it's a non-stop scarface movie yeah yeah
you got it you got the money got the
other seven of you
what just happened we thank you
what's going on they're cutting you
they're they're putting you in a
commercial for bone saws as they're
cutting you in half you know
put this dress on and then take out your
take your pants off and this is gonna
get you big time
it's gotten sick man here's a question
right here that came in from someone
this isn't live jim this is uh just a
man that sent this right here
sure what up jim huge fan man
man ever since half baked man
anyways i've been a comedian for about
five years
what do you think the future is for us
uh here with kovid going on
by the way man why eyes always look so
high gang gang
um future question what is kind of we
have do you think some of the future i
mean
things slowed down during covet for sure
i mean a lot of stages are still open
it's one of the reasons why i
ended up coming here because stages are
open and because it's a free state here
you know but
um but yeah it's what do you think man
where do you see kind of some comedy
going like do you see anything different
does this stage still hold the same
like this is the last point of uh
i'll tell you what after doing last
night in uh
um zany's last night
i felt like i was in a 2000 seat theater
wow the electricity of of
people was explosive and there was a
it was a a woman a little older on my
right chatter
and and i went a mustache
she's she's eating her chips and
everyone's like ah
and i turned away are you okay you're
not having fun
and sure i'm just enjoying being out i'm
just having my chips
and i'm just so happy i have a mask on
i'll start paying attention a minute
and i laughed so hard what i feel you
the crowd cheer
there's a um live is never going to die
even if we have to go back to the 20s
and do it in people's houses
you're not going to stop that right
that's the will of humanity you can't
stop us
from being social as though they're
doing their darndest
yeah whoever they are but they're doing
a they're doing everything they can to
scare the living life
out of you to to try to convince you
that you are capable of
murdering your grandmother and feeling
guilty about
about hugging people and being with one
another
to me that's that's the cult
oh you know they point fit that's the
real cult the ones that are going
you know are you ready to live your life
knowing you killed your grandmother
you're the cult you're the problem that
stems from
pure dark there's nothing good about
that
we're only here one time we need to hug
we need to see smiles
we need to touch that's humanity you
take that away
it's over yeah if you take that away
what's the point i'm just here i'm just
a
you know i'm a piece of a video game
that can't even really play know and
that's what they want
and people falling for it all clients
say they would watch the news like this
that's great what the numbers are going
up the numbers are going up
the numbers are going up where you mask
wear your mask
when you mask wear your mask grandma
killer
grandma killer grandma killer
oh my god get back in your cage yeah
please
oh i don't know what you know people
always ask me like i don't know where
we're going
because every time i think i know where
we're going uh
then boom the the tick tock verdi person
takes off and then the instagram person
takes off
and the podcast takes off no one knows
what what people wanna
or comedy is wide open everyone needs to
laugh
and there's and and there's
every extreme type of comedy
so it's never gonna die you need to
laugh
but back to that guy's question i don't
know where it's going i don't know
i don't know i have no clue i'm not
worried about it i can only do what i
can
control right 53
you know i still need someone to help me
with i i need this guy
i just found this guy that's shawn yeah
i just found my sean
i'm like you need to edit yeah i started
packing
my i'm looking at my podcast yeah i've
been doing it but then i stopped because
i don't i
have to call the guy right yeah you got
to get around that knows them
the person would and the he calls the
girl
yeah oh my god with the cables yes i
just
i think i could post in two weeks i need
sean yeah
who goes okay first of all the lights
like i was watching
what i filmed wednesday and there's a
shadow over my face every two seconds
like i got i gotta look somewhat
professional yeah i gotta my microphones
don't look anything like this
look like oh yeah bebop that [ __ ] ham
radio style
yes so i i need i just found a sean i
have to tighten up
but you have to you have to adjust
people would love it your voice needs to
be out there i think you know people
would absolutely love it
uh it's there's there's neat guys
starting when dana carvey started one
he's a good human being oh dana carver
is this exceptional man
he's a good human being he's such a
sweet uh dad
and he's a loving guy and he's very
he's realistic he's like respectful of
everyone but
also realistic and so smart that you
just have to listen and when he talks
kind of
um and he can drift from a story into
like a
into funny like from so real and funny
like in like
like a stream almost you don't even
notice it flowing you know like the
guy's blood to the [ __ ] drain you
know yeah
yes yeah and he's uh he's like you say
he's a real human being yeah oh
yeah i'm always rooting for dana carvey
yeah i'm always checking like what's
going on with david carvey yeah he's a
neat guy and he got a he took off a show
business for a while
and went and just lived his life and
raised his kids in
san francisco yeah i
did you guys work together i don't even
remember i don't know a ton he hosted he
hosted when i was on sunday live
okay he couldn't have been nicer
couldn't have been more giving
couldn't have been uh he was he was like
the big brother
that came he was the frat brother that
came so let me tell you about the frat
house here
right oh nice and let me tell you about
the ways and yeah
so he was he's always tr he was charming
and you remember those things you
remember when you crossed people's paths
what they were um that's a good point
but i do i do uh it was right after
a guy like him it was at the end of snl
half-baked
came out and i was just done with the
whole industry
really as i was done were you burnt out
also though
physically and stuff do you think from i
mean were you just exhausted emotionally
yeah emotion emotional
it was it was it was so exhausting
sign it live was
it it was as much as
as the times when you're up to bat you
hit the ball in the upper deck
to just to get to the plate
is so exhausting yeah this one takes
your idea
right this one takes party idea and does
it but you can't say no because he's the
one that's in the room with lauren
picking the sketches
yeah and then you finally step up to
this person and now you're a problem
and you're like it was it was and my
wife
my wife there's times when i
really wanted to knock her flat on her
back because she just
she don't get it you don't get it yeah
and she'd be like no
you don't get it you don't get it
i can see what you don't see and so i
remember
she was looking at me in new york city
and she goes
you know why you just quit
or are you cr are you are you listening
to yourself
you don't quit you grind through dopey
are you seriously out of your mind
you're just nubs in a wheelchair don't
you even
yeah she's like you smoke what's her
name what's her first name d yeah d
don't you even [ __ ] know dude you
don't know [ __ ] you don't
quit show [ __ ] i'm on top of the game
you see his tattoo yeah he sees that
dude says
snl alum
danny ackroyd volusia alum carvey
farley i'm in it i'm in the club and you
can't take those stripes up
i'm in it yeah millions of people trying
to get me i'm in
it yeah there's people buying my doll
yeah
people doing that in aisles right now so
she's going dead guys a lot of dead guys
die like that
you have a guy on i'm a detective just
saying hey we got another uh
we got another um uh jim brew
impersonator over here guys come see it
yeah look at this
he's dropping the douche that was it
shows over stunk like a sonic gun trying
to keep the flies out it's the tough
part
here's a question from a guy right here
that came let's finish up so dee got you
out
but having her perspective helped is
that what you're saying or no it was
scary as hell
but her perspective has always helped on
many things that have happened in my
life
many things that have happened but she's
like look at you
you smoking pot non-stop you're becoming
a
an angry person uh and it's just
it's consuming your life and you don't
you always
this one's you're talking about stealing
but she's like i saw my own two eyes
why do you need so bad you're talented
like you know you don't
you don't you just don't yeah and
we did and i remember
no matter who we had we had producers
movie producers she didn't kiss me
i don't like that guy's an [ __ ] he
made this movie in this movies and he
made bridges in madison county yeah he's
he's an [ __ ] yeah
and there and and this guy made babe pig
in the city
it has been reported that americans are
overpaying on car insurance by over 21
billion dollars
silly americans but searching for a
better deal can take too long you got to
get on the internet you got to keep this
window open do this one call this person
you got to call 40 people
and next thing you know you you somebody
stole your car
the zebra.com is the nation's leading
car insurance comparison site
because it's the only place you can
compare quotes side by side from over
100 providers
and choose the best for you in 90
seconds or less
plus they will never sell your
information to the spammers
so you won't get all those unwanted
calls or emails you just answer a few
questions
it's a few questions so many people ask
you questions all the time
you can handle this techcrunch calls the
zebra kayak
for auto insurance how much can you save
on your car and home insurance
find out find out fast go today and
start saving at the zebra.com
theo that's the zebra.com
t-h-e-o spelled t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot com slash t-h-e-o
why pay extra if you don't have to do
you have a hard time taking pills huh
hey there buddy hey hey i'm
norm mcdonald hi uh uh the thing
what do you call this thing it's like uh
do you have a hard time taking pills huh
you're not alone
you're not alone i have a hard time
sometimes i take a big pill i can't
swallow it
cough it back up and i'll chop it up and
grill it
and eat it in small baby bites if you
like sex you'll love
bluechew.com if you want sex they can
help
at bluechew.com you get the first
chewable
with the active ingredients of
sildenafil and tata lawful
bluechew.com their affiliated physicians
work with you to find the dosage
an active ingredient that is best for
you to keep your wiener pop in
a consult is free so it's cheaper than
those other two
medicines that you hear about all the
time it only takes a few minutes to
connect with a bluetooth.com affiliated
physician
if you don't know about your wiener or
what's going on inside of it
well get blue chew you and your partner
will love it
here's a great deal for you support the
podcast
support the podcast visit bluechew.com
and get your first order free
when you use promo code theo that's
right
get that wiener on daddy you feel me
just pay five dollars shipping
that's b l u e c h ew
dot com promo code t h e
o um what's this guy up to
yeah what is this [ __ ] homeowner and
we started a family what
these guys so that's the end of the
story and we started a family and we
started that yeah
yeah now i'm three kids deep and
pregnant that's how it is and
pregnant that's right it's what happened
it is we were done with
with the snl went to san fran let's do
this
kid came out his head was all stretched
it was a mess
hey man how you doing um jim want to
give a shout
out to first off madam high school and
jacob's pizzeria
uh chester new jersey i know i know
you're familiar with that area
uh talking speaking of new jersey wanted
to ask you is a question
um give me some underrated
new jersey stand-up comics did i know
there's so much talent in our state uh
and i know
you got a good pulse on that so give me
give me three names that
maybe we don't know about that i should
be following is the stages open there
yes no um
that's a fair answer yes i know yes the
answer is yes because i was doing um
like tuesday nights at the stress
factory oh yeah
but he has the setup outside
which is bigger than the inside
and they were he really did it smart he
tented the whole thing in
heat i mean it was in december it was
freezing
but the only mishap is behind you
is the parking garage so you know you're
15 minutes in
and there's
one more boys yeah slap and slap
it yeah and you go and then spousal
abuse don't forget
yeah you stupid shut your face what were
you looking at him for
i wasn't knocking my hand all day and
you get out of the car you and
so uh but then i just played
uh uh what's the place it's it's
it's in red bank i played there
vogel the outdoor place was it indoor it
was indoor
uh yeah the red bank it's like a it's
called the vogel
there is there is the count basie yeah
count base that's what i played at but
they can't do count basie
so now they have the vogel which was
only it was a beautiful
theater within the count basie oh nice
and so
but it was you know it's like 200 people
it's still awesome
to wear masks no it's the first show i
did would have to wear a mask
it was awkward was it yeah it was weird
you could tell they were annoyed
and they can't even and what if they
want to do i guess they got no snacks
huh
no snacks they had snacks but they're
literally like make [ __ ] just
like that yeah because the governor
lives in the town
and he comes in i understand you're not
keeping up with the rules and
regulations
this is for your safety
you don't want to kill your grandmother
do you yeah
i see we are at 27 there will be a rest
made
it's crazy man yeah i just don't
understand in most people's minds
because it's crazy some of the smartest
people i know
go along with everything that's going on
here so easily it's like
how do you not see so what the numbers
on some
on some news channel that their only
goal is to keep you watching
but if you drive by the hospital or if
you look buy a
you can go to a clinic a walk-in clinic
here there's nobody that like
how does it not way to people that to at
least alert in their heads
something is not right here i
i think more people know
something's not right i think also
uh they're doing a real good job with
the eye candy fear
and i'm wondering
if it's gonna break
like uh when you're on the highway and
everyone's afraid to pass the state
trooper oh yeah
even though he's going 60 you're like
well i can't get pulled over against 65.
yeah and then the one finally does
you're like let's follow this guy
yeah i saw his sweat looks like then you
should enough
i kind of feel the minute if it ever
happens
and it has to happen yeah where
people go we're not shutting down but
you need
a couple people to do yeah you find me
so what you can't
none of these things are laws right
right if you ever end up going to a
court you're gonna you're gonna somehow
win but you win yeah
you it's scared to we find you so what
we're gonna revoke you to go ahead
yeah you can't you don't have
you can't make the law so you know we
could talk about it's all we want but no
one's doing anything
right and that that's the scary part but
it is bizarre to me
how many people will watch this and then
they'll and then they'll come after me
foaming at the mouth going you know and
their thing is always the same people
like you're crying
yeah or you'll be people died yeah
and i feel like going no do you know how
many people
that you believe died because of what
you're watching right
you know i was on a podcast like i
couldn't even find a dead person i bet
you if you gave me two hours right now
i couldn't find a dead person from covid
if i went door to door i'm talking
banging
even breaking and entering doing
anything coming in the back door
smoking people out doing a fire in the
back standing by the front with a net
or uh i bet i could i'm serious bro i
bet i couldn't find
one [ __ ] dead person i haven't found
one i have
i have a couple first of all i had it uh
my daughter had it my wife had it
um another good friend his whole family
had it
for us it was a bit it was a cold right
it was a bad cold
um oh yeah i agree i believe there's a
flu i believe there's a
a special variant of a flu there's
always a flu in the winter
yeah there's flus there's coals
bronchitis
it's all gone it's funny how all that
stuff is gone yeah
it's just gone and people will hear this
and be like no it's not me
but it is though if you think about all
the time you heard about it like you
just have to trust the logic in my head
i don't even think i'm coming from a
place of judgment i think i'm just
coming from a real place inside of me
that feels like
this doesn't make sense makes zero sense
that's common sense and that's and what
they're pushing is the whole
it's science science doesn't have common
sense but you can manipulate
numbers you can manipulate science to
scare tactic that's the difference
so you can put science as your religion
and as your
fact or whatever it still doesn't define
logic yeah and i'd rather die by some
logic man like my mom's
my mother's hard work and been working
her life she's like if i die
i die you know like i don't want to be i
don't want to never see anybody the last
four years of my life
listen and this is a good story but i
always bring this up i don't want to bum
people out it's not like what but
my wife 2012 uh
she had breast cancer all right boom
breasts come off the blood she's gonna
go on natural wow breast off huh
oh yeah that history whole shebang 2014
it comes backs in the lymph nodes gotta
take it out do the chemo and all that
jazz
um we are now 20 2016
end of the year um hey
bad news it's everywhere it's everywhere
butter brain
what do we do well she's got a couple
months we'll give her pain
medicine or she can live on a trial
so she's been on a trial drug in
philadelphia
it'll be it'll just pass four years
thank you god now the point of that
story is
we've already been living the life of
common sense
and she too oh the family and everyone
else are the ones that go
you know you got to be very careful and
it and you know your immune system and
jim shouldn't travel she's like you know
what i
no one knows when we're going to die
yeah i'm not going to live recklessly
but you're not going to control my life
and how i should live
and the way i should live because you
are scared
and my wife and i live it's interesting
the way
we live and and we when we would go
somewhere if i saw someone sick
i'd go hey man don't go over there
because that guy's sick but i'm not
gonna ask the whole place
to wear a mask and and double down
because my what
that's my responsibility right that's my
thing
that that's part of the you know if you
if you're 400 pounds and you got
you get the gout three times a year and
you have diabetes back
you gotta be careful with everything but
back off the sugar shrimp for sure
exactly whatever you're doing you gotta
take it down a level
bronchitis is gonna take you out yeah a
hard staircase
is going to take you out so this whole
mentality
is pure insanity and it makes no sense
and you know what
i don't care about people's backlash
anymore yeah
i know it's right right i know it's in
my heart of heart
i know what common sense god gave us
common sense
yeah thought process instinct your
instinct tells you
something weird is going on yeah common
sense tells you
something weird is going yeah nobody you
can't
so yeah you're right on it man you got
to live your life
yeah i want to live my life not like an
idiot but you live your life
yeah yeah i want and i want to like
that's what i want it's like i think
that's the thing
and like you know a lot of people have
also the the side effects of people
dying
or struggling from like um being hurt
from like addiction or not seeing their
loved ones broken-hearted
the gate they had a fellow beautiful
fellow gay gentleman that was a piano
player at the comedy store
and he died because a lot of people
think he died just because he got so
lonesome
you know and it's that's guesstimated
but the guy for 25 years had been a
pianist right there for
the best you know my youngest daughter
has has put on weight
she's depressed she hates school
she used to love it because she's got to
wear a mask that won't let him stay
together
she it's like being in a cube cubicle
her friends it's it's the worst thing
you can be doing to humanity and anyone
that wants to fiercely defend it
i'm ready to go at it with you yeah i
don't have to tell you you're not gonna
control me
and the billions of people that feel the
same way hey man it's over and there's a
lot of people that
yeah there's a lot of people that feel
the same way and we just have to start
speaking up in small ways and also i
think just speaking up in our actions
you know
like be respectful and but also just
speak up in our actions like
that doesn't mean go out and do
something bad or something aggressive it
just means stand your ground for what
you believe also
stand your ground do be fearless
yeah fearless and i you know i was on a
podcast where i don't know
um who was it christopher fitzsimmons oh
greg fitzsimmons
fitzgerald and he's he's uh i've known
him a while but he's
he toes the line he's he's he's in it
yeah he's in the the la world and he
keeps going back and i just kept going
king hitting the ball right don't give
me that nonsense bro
and he's a good guy and we can hang
forever but
he tried a little bit like no no he's
going to believe this
like yeah makes a lot of sense yeah
scene with my own eyes
you know there's a guy we have this crew
uh where i live uh and we it's an
amazing community that we built
and this is what i'm going to start
bringing on my podcast because they're i
i i don't mind being funny but also my
big
struggle with you is yeah you could say
it i've struggled with pornography
mostly
i don't struggle with that oh you don't
no no no i i probably did when i was
younger
i think everybody does it's a racket but
i'll tell you why that's bad too
oh it's bad it's horrible i'll tell you
why that's that's
real bad that is another oversaturated
well targeted
um and it's it's
i always i always say this you remember
the first time you saw it
oh yeah drawing this dude nick in our
town
two dollars he would draw you some cuda
for the weekend right
so you'd hit him up on friday or
thursday night if you wanted a good
sketch right
but even on friday afternoon you could
get a a scribble i remember this and he
would freaking los you know he'd launch
you out that two dollar hit ron you'd
keep it all weekend
and then somebody chiseled a set of tits
into like a birch tree
and people would go out there and jerk
off by it
kids and adults bro not at the same time
but you know you had to be respectful
but you know everybody was out there i
remember that it was a good time for me
it was
it was phil's dad's tape oh
phil come on and we were let's call phil
phil and gil dad get his [ __ ] 80 year
old dad on the line
and talk about the lives he's ruined
phil's dad's tapes
he i was i don't care what anyone says
when you first see
you're traumatized it's crazy you look
at the whole world differently
you look at women differently you you go
from staring at them to staring
at them yeah and you think that's why
and if you notice it's gotten more
violent more evil
as time went like this whole thing oh
yeah who came up with
if it can't even do that smack smack
smack
who said i love you so much smack smack
yeah i love you so
god i love you yeah that is legal rape
a lot of heimlich maneuvers all there's
all types of like you know
let me wait i got a punch in your temple
right before you orgasm let me know when
you
let me pink you said you were orgasm you
said you were going there
come on we had to do this again
[Laughter]
are you sure this time good yeah
okay crazy it's legal rape
and i yeah it's crazy that that and like
that it's just it's freaking bizarre man
it's the dark arts dude i was addicted
to it for a while and i do pretty good
these days you know but
every now and then it seeps in man you
know it's hard to keep it out
i will not see now when i
i once i had daughters that's another
whole
oh that'd be different i have three
girls so it in my head i'm always like
oh god if if i do this is it gonna come
back around
yeah i'm one of those guys if i do this
that's weiner karma dog
it is but you're right and i'm like
someone's gonna come in
and and my and the kid's gonna be into
this
and it all sparked but that's how i i i
think like that
that's that energy flow yeah because it
could be possible here's a guy right
here who used to be a mime who [ __ ]
is recovering
he's a recovering mime look at this
question yeah beautiful fella
like before we do it i'm going to
predict okay
it's definitely in the half-baked world
i could see that maybe why what makes
you say that his eyes
he looks a little lit up oh he does look
a little lit up on this little little
pink but i don't know he's very
confident with the shirt and
hat he looks like his name would be sam
he seemed like he has a very
like a name that's kind of ambiguous i'm
gonna say
it's more of the uh midwestern
like midwestern name like trevor
okay yeah but trevor i could see trevor
trance we had a god bless
grant yeah like a trend yeah we had a
guy last name
brunch growing up varsity yeah
what's up vars
let's see what he's got what up theo
what up jim brewer
my name is danny i'm from clearwater
florida um
jim i got a question for you man so i
actually went to coconuts comedy club
and did a comedy set there on open mic
and i heard that that's where you
started out doing comedy so i just got a
question for you man
how is it getting started in comedy and
what do you recommend
to be able to go with the time limit
because the first time i did comedy i
swear to god i lasted 30 seconds and
then i said
i can't do this and i walked off stage
the second time i did comedy
i went 30 seconds over the five limit
open mic time limit
so uh yeah words and advice would be
appreciated much love gang
gang theo gang bro well if you're carlos
smith c
now if you went that long dude you're
basically you're you're dave chappelle
you've done it bro you saw if you went
that long the second time you're doing
fine
yeah yeah i 100 100 and yes i used to uh
do
coconuts that's kind of the first
chain that started giving me lots of
work and yeah
a lot of them were remodes yeah
remodeled
at the uh happy hour it didn't matter i
just i wanted to work so
and i was way off with that kid that kid
has a good soul oh yeah nice kid
they they used to have you know people
have been murdered at every vermont at
every ramada
there's a uh there's been a murder at
every ramada really now yeah
finally it took finally it was about
you know i was waiting for the hundred
percent here they were at 99
for a real long time they were hovering
i'm like when is biloxi
it's right next to a greyhound station i
thought it would go first
come on but yeah man pretty cool
there's a website that tracked it there
was like one of those like uh uh
this is like probably four years ago
that there was a the website finally
closed down but there was like murders
at i guess every ramadan you
you married uh i'm not married explains
everything i'm willing
i get and the reason i say is like wow
if i had i'd
cause i couldn't imagine looking stuff
like that
up but if i was alone yeah and single
i'd be looking off some wild stuff just
dropping
facts that people weren't even prepared
for me to slap down
are you ready for this ping yeah
yeah you know tarantulas have heavy feet
like this um
i uh when you look back on some of those
times do you feel good about them like
when you look back on your on your
hollywood times i feel great about
everything i did
yeah because i i do i love the journey
i've been on
i love that uh
the move i made and i i did have
resentment for a while
with a lot of things uh i had
animosity and anger what was anger about
do you feel like it like because it's
hard
anger's so hard to pinpoint sometimes
and a lot of times it has to do with
myself you know i find um
because i can be angry at others but
they're just doing their thing they
don't [ __ ] it you know
they're just true you know this was a
different anger i
i'm i'm really i'm one of those guys too
where i get
angry for
injustice oh yeah so
that infuriates me
that makes me wanna that makes me wanna
fight
yeah um and yeah i want things to be
fair
just be fair and not for me there's
there was
something that was taken from me
and and sold oh i see like a project or
something you had
yep right on and given to someone and i
don't think that person even knows
and it blew up so big wow so when i'm
home
with my little babies and and trying to
i wanted to stay home um so i took a
radio gig
and i'm watching that
that was a tough period and that's where
that's where
see now i do have like a deep moral
godly
thing and and i'm not afraid to talk
about anymore so at that time
my wife i'll never forget she's like jim
as i was in my basement look i was like
right there i met him
and i called him and then he gave
he sold it to them i'm talking she's
like jimmy i got 20 million dollars
i'm gonna ask so i'm gonna put this out
there
i was ready you turned into henry
rollins at the very end the first
all that i believed until the very end i
feel like you turned into like henry
rollins and black flag you know
yes i feel like yes and she goes i'll
never forget
jim let him have it i said all right
seriously is there something wrong with
you
is something wrong with you or something
right you don't get so many
if that's all they got they don't have
what you got
i got she's like you got a beautiful
house
we got a couple acres you said you want
to be home with your girl you're home
with your girls yeah
you you go to a radio show for two hours
a day
with your best friends that's fun
yeah but gotcha don't let them have it
if that's all they got
it'll catch up to him cut two
five years later this one crash
burn people turn on him this one
plummets plummets
beyond hard to the point where i started
feeling badly oh man
yeah it's terrible to have the and and
the amazing part of it is and i don't
wanna i don't want to allude to names or
anything yeah no and i'm not asking you
to
but what is amazing for people what it
can help is
years later see i got to hold my dad
to his last breath which is all i ever
begged like i said god please
all i want in life is i don't want that
man alone i want to be
i want to be there for him world war ii
vet
grew up in in newport in in uh uh
dayton kentucky kentucky just not even
the real dayton
no across the river
from just 10 kids no
mother i mean
as raw as you can get i didn't realize
my dad
had that in him until we saw johnny cash
for the first time together no huh yeah
i was like 10 years old
long island um westbury music fair
and he came out did the whole hello um
and he goes yeah yeehaw we live in long
island
yeah he goes i was born in kentucky
i'm a kentucky guy heck williams senior
not junior
junior can he the senior juniors
and then i started so the point of the
story is i'm all over the place but
he never complained in life this man
could have complained about everything
war for years uh his his first so
he was alcohol just the things he never
complained
always there for me couldn't he was
older
so he couldn't really interact much but
he was always there solid
never talk i think i remember four
conversation my dad wow but they were
powerful
they were powerful he was just step in
like are you talking about when he
started playing with your donkey in the
pictures
yeah when i went through that phase he
saw the picture he's like hey
well wait wait let your mother see that
it's really disturbing
yeah enough with that yeah not for that
[ __ ]
none of that [ __ ] hey we're gonna play
your time
that shit's gonna get you trouble okay
daddy
so he was really old he he was
he was uh 45 when he had me my mom was
i was an accident my mom had wow my mom
22 to have a kids older
back then right back then so you know my
mom would tell me she should have like
three martinis saying yeah
you were supposed to be an abortion
because they said you'd be [ __ ]
that's what you were saying you're like
i got pretty close ma i said well look
at me yeah
at least i tried i tried to try my best
well they said i beat down syndrome
in our town man because they thought i
had it for like the first year and a
half a month no kidding
and then they literally told my parents
that i beat it dude and so it was like
it was like this kind of thing in our
area wow pretty crazy
and so to be able to go through that in
life
and still have what i have now i could
tour what i want and my kids we found an
amazing
i've been all over the world my kids all
over i mean africa and safari
really been doing fun stuff huh oh yeah
bands i love metallica ac dc
i mean it's like a living dream and so
watching these other people crash it was
a couple years ago
i went to l.a to promote something
and we already discussed how i feel
about it and i found this little
neighborhood place cross street was a
ihop
i don't know in the name place really
cool little hotel
and i went out to eat and it was a
little place on
up the street it was almost like a
mexican and pizza
and i was just sitting there and this
guy came up to me
one of the people and i go uh
hey and he goes hey man
i just want to tell you i i i really
respect what you did with your dad
and you made this documentary and i just
uh
i just i i respect what you do
and all i saw was that that was like
grace
and healing because if this person knew
how i felt
years before about this person
and the other person involved
and now here they are coming back i see
where they're going
and where my life is and it's
they're hard to get through but you
don't know the long term right when you
stick to your thing
it's you just don't know when you're
chasing
it's amazing you need that balance
um yeah yeah that makes sense yeah 100
it's hard to know like what the moment
right now that it
is part of a bigger painting you know
it's so hard to know it's impossible
and of course the way that we're built
now with instantaneocity and doing stuff
right now
and this and that and jack and jill and
jeff you know doing whatever you want
you could jerk off out of your pocket
you know
yes you could get somebody to bring a
mountain dew or you could you know you
could kill some there's
websites you can get people killed you
can do it all in a second yes there's
there's so much like i control
everything that there's
never any like i'm gonna let the higher
powers and the powers that be control
things
i'm gonna live in the plan you know i
tell you what and and the more
feel the more i've done that in the last
five ten years where i go you know what
and and this is this is where
things really shifted for me around 2008
and i started changing my stand up i
started changing my
outlook i always feared that people
would see me as like oh we
like all moral and stuff and it's like i
feared that
why don't why did i fear that what's
wrong with being that
yeah or trying to be also it's a goal
it's a it's just a it's not even a goal
it's just an attempt
yeah and it's it's a it's a way of
living it's wrong which is giving
goodness you know
so the more the minute i tapped into
that and the more i said you know what
like now i'm going out and touring yes i
want to make money blah blah blah
but the end i get i get so much more out
of
i know this sounds corny touching lives
it is i've done it a lot
and and i the more i go i'm going to do
this
because i want to you know it's and i
think a lot has to do with my wife my
wife
she goes so she's she's found jesus
years ago and that was another hole
right like whoa
whoa whoa whoa what's going on here yeah
it was boom it was a powerful story
but just i didn't see it coming well
it's also when
when people are go and that experience
for people is their own experience
finding a higher power finding a faith
that kind of thing it's there
so even if you're like it's such a
personal experience that
yeah it's hard to really kind of share
with somebody in a lot of ways and for
them to kind of um
and you're instantly judged oh yeah oh
especially these days dude yeah
you're a freak or you're you know you
think you're like ah she's nothing like
that
yeah you know she'll do things like this
she'll go i get on the metallica i'm on
i'm touring with metallica yeah
for me that was a legend yeah this is
the greatest
this is the greatest this is better than
any sitcom yeah i don't want to be in
the movies i'm torn
with my metallica guy you kidding me
yeah
so um and you guys are out there right
who's the other opening man
and also there is none [ __ ] i'm the
opener that's crazy dog
so yeah and i had but before you worked
in metallica had you worked with a band
and it didn't work because it you know
it never works for anyone
uh no
i i did a little something in front of
alice in chains once because it made me
go up less
they were like come on
birthday party at perry farrell's house
dude a friend of mine lee
like they knew the family or whatever so
he went over there for his
one-year-old's party
and uh me and perry would [ __ ] sit in
the library just
and literally i could not understand one
word that he said
he was describing different books to me
on this shelf
bro i had no idea what was going on is
that that's uh
jane's addiction too right it's uh they
came on senate live
and i'll never forget this i was so
hopped up so they did the first song
and they were they were damaged damaged
so in between they're like i'll never
forget i'm hanging out and they go
he goes perry goes hey
can we do that song over and uh
the producer goes it was live
matter of fact your second song is cut
they're the first band
i got their second song cut away cut
they just because they were so ripped i
had now i have to go look at it watch it
the first time they were on sunday live
it's probably between 95 and 98
and they did this hey look it up sean
bang bang bang bang and when they were
finished
i just remember going i didn't do that
again they went now you're done you're
done for tonight
you're out show's over that was live
let's hit this guy we're coming back
we're all right let's see what this
guy's doing right here
this is jimmy john right here jimmy john
was on here uh john lau
towed he's from illinois and he i love
how you do this the guy who started
jimmy john's
um this is really cool wait what did you
guys start jimmy
no the guy who started jimmy johnson's
on here this guy resembles him very well
okay
okay all right what's up theo
the legend jim brewer what's going on
this is matt in south florida
jim i've admired you for god knows how
long
you have shared so much of your life
throughout your career especially the
stories on the stern show you've left no
stone unturned in terms of your
transparency
but anybody who knows you knows that
you're probably one of the more
admirable people in this world the care
that you gave your father
even when he was going through those
difficult times was uh definitely
remarkable to see
what's one piece of advice you would
give to somebody who um
does have a special relationship with
their father or parent
in general and maybe fears those later
years in life
um you know knowing that they want to
care for them but knowing what's coming
next
hopefully we can all meet it as
gracefully as you did
um and obviously uh have a special
relationship like you did
so thanks for listening gang gang bro
where where
when is this air it could probably go up
tomorrow but we could do it whenever
okay well it doesn't matter so so i
won't say the hotel i'm at okay
so the hotel i'm at this just happened
last night
i cut my i have a cut in here and my
nail
is is slit to here so i call downstairs
all right do you have a nail clipper and
you're like now darling we ain't got one
and walgreens is closed
captioning not
condom available tomorrow and you go get
you but there was another guy
and i don't know if he was a janitor or
whatever because he didn't look like he
was checking
he's probably loitering but yeah
he's always there he's always there he's
behind it he gets it
he's worked his way behind whoever that
is but a xeroxer
yeah he's already worked his way the guy
in there just hears the bell
yeah right so he he comes and he goes uh
jim same thing goes man i love
i watch that stuff you do with your dad
he goes i'm going through this
right now wow and the best advice i tell
people
is
the hardest thing we go through in life
is watching our parents struggle
because they're your rocks they're your
idols
they're your source of of power they're
your
they're invincible and
his father was only 66 years old which
is still young
and he said he got in a terrible
accident smashed his head
uh it wasn't his fault
he was horseback riding he was uh in a
horseback race no
he he was sitting i i still don't know
he wasn't a civil warrior
okay he was part of a vote oh man i said
not that rifle that's the real one
cheddar damn what's wrong with you sorry
billy all right he's bleeding bad yeah
he's bleeding bad dog
he's bleeding bad dad it's always i'm
gonna go out on a limb and say 80
of people in cwr's are father sons baby
yeah you're right
so he goes um and i sti there was part
of me want to ask this question because
i
i still can't all i heard was his father
was sitting down
and someone was undoing the hitch on the
car
or the truck and the hitch smash his
head
and i couldn't visualize and i wasn't
gonna deal like well all right so what
happened
he goes he was so he's damaged and he
still can't remember he's he's done he
can't walk
whoa your dad's a fried egg
so he goes and and he slowly start i
said you know what the worst part is
when you start
oh he goes you know he's kind of pissing
all over and i went
is he like you know the toughest thing
for me was the dry heaves
my father dropped a deuce and i'm like
oh you dry heat
my neck would hurt is it because it's
also your father's excrement
i mean hard and you know
but what i realized was the minute
they can't drive i try to explain to
this guy i went listen the best thing
you could do
taking care of anyone is you have to
remove all selfishness
this is really getting in my way i ain't
got time for this i'm really big this is
not a good timing in my life
this is not blah blah blah because
that's what happens it's really hard to
put that aside well my sister should do
it but
let's do it maybe we can hire someone to
do it
they are they reach a point you got to
understand
the last thing you want in life is now i
can't drive
now i can't go to the bathroom myself
and they don't want to let you know i
mean before this happened
you said your father was driving around
damn well now he's got a
can you go get me do you mind just going
to get a couple things from the grocery
store
uh he's feeling that a
depression he knows he's gonna die
um so you gotta put yourself my fa i'll
never forget
uh i was coming home from i i could my
next book is gonna be the top 10 cities
and my father crapped himself
in public i love that public i had great
stories
but i found the humor in it you got to
laugh at it
and one of the last ones was he we were
uh
just got off the plane he looked at me
he's like i gotta go
and to me he said he'd go which he went
oh so he's one of them tiny planes to
get him off i'm dry even
i get him into uh the the united
president's club right i said i got i
need i need to get in here
yeah i need some we can't do this and
yeah this ain't gonna happen
coach it ain't gonna happen so we get in
there and i'm dry even
and i had an extra pair of sweatpants i
just remember him looking at me defeated
oh
he said you're never gonna bring me
around again are you
we're never gonna travel anymore and i
it hit me so
hard and i just went
no we're gonna travel it's not gonna
feed you until we get to where we're
going man
i just i can't feed you i can't have
anything in your system
i'm going to starve you hard so the
i guess yeah he he laughed
but he wasn't a laugh or he'd just go
like this
that was him laughing yeah that was me
crushing with my dad yeah
but uh the best thing is put your life
into there you don't know what they're
where they're at mentally so all you
gotta do is constantly cheer i just get
my my
dad once he couldn't drive gave up on
life wouldn't shower
wouldn't wouldn't shave so i'd have to
turn on some hank williams
and johnny cash and i'd make it a whole
i didn't know what a barber shop was so
i'd
set up like a barber shop and his
bathroom in it and i'd be sitting
driving him nuts busting his balls
okay
oh my god dad this is bad i stuck on
like really bad
but we needed that we needed to scrub
his ass
like dad you think i like scrubbing your
ass like ew you [ __ ] way up in there
would y'all be in the shower together no
god no no i could i couldn't do that
now i've stepped in with him yeah that's
what i'm talking about bro teamwork and
i bring up
i like it yeah anyway
because when they get older they can't
wipe their ass oh yeah
it's hard now it's exactly so it's sit
i'm at that age too i'm like why i gotta
write my ass again
and i go around back a lot of times i go
i always go around
you do yeah wow i just started doing
that what do you mean
yeah i went uh hold the nuts up
frontward for a long time
oh damn you come this way yeah yeah it's
crazy
wow i never went that many my life
really yeah i don't want it on my
no not will you just stop before you're
nuts oh that's crazy
that way as much as possible but that's
such a six year old movie still doing
that
i feel and i have a big butt so to go
around my butt is tougher
and i have short arms big butt wait a
minute so you coming up here what if you
were on the front
side no you don't miss i mean you're
it's really you kind of scoot up on the
bowl
i think it's oh it's really practical to
me honestly look you know
we recently got the website done and the
fella that did it fella i grew up with
named timmy
beautiful guy beautiful slender fell
about six foot six
one probably six one maybe six one and a
half but anyway
he has a company called modify and they
do web cidery
they're good people over there our
website is looking
better than ever it was effortless quick
like magic
modify now has the last website plan
it's the best option out there
for any business that doesn't want to do
it themselves you can't do the html
and drag and drop and this and that next
thing you know you
you'll be back to the business card
modify's last website plan really seems
to be
too good to be true but it's not no cost
to build
no contract unlimited updates unlimited
support
custom design easy editing tools future
redesigns
all of that all of that for just two
hundred and forty nine dollars a month
the best part is they do it all for you
to learn more about the last website
you'll ever need
visit modify.com theo to schedule your
free
demo today that's modify with a ph
m-o-d-i-p-h-y dot com
slash t-h-e-o these guys don't
f around gang ba-boom
in case you don't speak espanol
in case you don't speak el chino chinese
that means
chinese i just learned it from babel the
number one selling
language learning app one of my goals
for the new year was to learn a new
language and babble
b-a-b-b-e-l has made the whole process
addictively
fun and easy with bite-sized lessons you
can use in the real world
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language
on the go they do that unlike the
infamous language classes you took in
high school where people are smoking
dope
stabbing each other
you can choose from 14 different
languages including spanish french
italian and
german german oh look at the girls
beautiful girls plus babel's speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your pronunciation and accent
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription
you'll get an additional three months
that's six total months man that's
almost a baby
that's six months for the price of three
just go to
babel.com and use promo code t-h-e-o
that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com code theo
for an extra three months free babble
babb el.com code theo
babble language for life learn the
language you want to learn man it's time
it's time you know my dad was 70 when i
was born my dad was really old and he
was
he was an older man so just hear you
talk about stories
about your dad yeah he was my dad was
born in 1910 right
what crazy bro crazy my first jokes were
all about growing up with like an old
dad and like
oh my gosh see i thought mine was 23
yeah 1923 1910
yeah it was crazy man but it's just
interesting like
like um i think just the things like i
would get i felt
i feel bad as i got older i was
embarrassed to my dad a lot just like
the way his skin would look like just
little things like
he'd fall asleep at the game like he'd
fall asleep dude my dad bought a car for
some black guys in our neighborhood and
so
he had this car that had these 22s in it
this delta cutlass 88 or something but
had these 22
speakers in the back of it right yeah so
he'd be listening like paul harvey like
you know like
yeah paul harvey good day
just at the [ __ ] loudest base you
could have just dead asleep in the
[ __ ] carpool line bro
we'd have to walk down to the car to get
in and the teacher knew we were so
embarrassed dude and it was just this
[ __ ]
sometimes we would make him drive and
walk down the block and then get in like
i don't know sometimes i still have like
this weird shame from like
just i just wasn't in a space to be
loving i was just like a like a kid
you know you didn't know i didn't know
my dad world war ii and all that like i
didn't
he would say to me he's like i ran a big
one eight and nine i'm like what does
that mean
yeah and even when you learn in school
you know you don't comprehend
and he'd watch the war things like i'm
not comprehending what's going on
you have to get older that's another
thing about just like the big picture of
life like
that's one thing i feel bad when people
die young because you just don't get to
see like how it all
kind of adds up and it all the balance
sheet
all averages out yeah and sometimes i
wonder
at least this is the only way it works
in my mind where
if someone die i've had people in my
life die young
and it's actually empowered
a certain amount of people their their
spirit
right and power like it happened for me
like it really
uh empowered me in a lot of ways a a
dear friend of mine
um what happened to him who was he she
it was a she
and we were we were best friends it was
florida it was before i went full-blown
into stand-up and she kept saying you
need to do stand-up
and she liked me but i didn't realize
she really liked me
and we lived right next door each other
but it was about
i was lost in florida i mean i grew up
in long island and
we grew up like brothers and sisters on
the same street our whole lives
and and we were brought we were brothers
and sisters and
and even when phil's dad's tape broke
out we were like now we're playing truth
or dares
like we were and then my parents we
just bought a house in florida what and
then i go down there and
people talk different and there's no
like well you just stripped me my life
um so she was kind of a saving grace she
was from boston
and uh and i it was
it was it was uh she was she was
we were we were bickering over something
happened i want to go into details
and then uh long story short i saw her
one night
i actually i was like god man i if
there's an opportunity to talk to her i
don't like this feeling i would talk to
her and sure enough after about two and
a half weeks she was sitting in a
breezeway as i pulled in late at night
and went over and like hey i'm sorry i
you know
i miss you i love you and we talked for
hours and she basically
told me like it was all her things were
closed and she's like you know i
couldn't go to the prom
and now i was on the beach and i met
this guy from boston that i went to
school with and he just moved down here
and he asked me the prom and
oh my gosh amazing and i gave her this
kiss and next day she's like tomorrow i
got photography class
you want to go and i didn't want to go
um yeah so i
purposely was like a little late mm-hmm
so i'm like hey mary and i got home
she died a car crashed but
that it was weird it was uh and that was
the beginning
of when i went to the funeral it was
very you know she was she was a senior
and so who were you
you were senior 19 19 and so she
i remember being the funeral and going
wow this is this is
not the way this is weird so i went
outside
with a couple friends so this is not
what she would want right now she wants
me to do calm she wanted blah blah and i
started
i started making everyone laugh and
started imitating what you'd be saying
to us right now and what we would be
doing
and everyone started laughing and then i
stopped like oh this is not cool because
now everyone's coming outside and
this ain't cool this ain't cool and they
went no no don't stop keep going
and then it was weird
uh that's powerful
because somebody's gone and you're
there's this pow there's this power of
like
of being like a valve release in a weird
way
it was and then i i stopped at her grave
before and i would talk to all the time
i'd have i don't even smoke but she'd
smoke and i'd have a cigarette start i
went to her grave where he left i'm like
hey man
i didn't realize how much he left
because her mom gave me these poems she
wrote about me i was like oh
wow and one of them was like
uh uh if i can't have him i'd rather
just not be here and i can love him from
a deeper place
oh wow damn
so i went to a i went to the grave and i
went a
a kirsten i just want to kristen i want
to tell you
look out for me do your best i'm not
sure i'll ever
meet anyone that loved me the way you
loved me
and i know i'm going to make it i'm
going to make it i'm gonna be a star
i pray to god i meet a girl before that
because i want her to fall in love with
me and not the star
i go i i know you're gonna be looking
after me and blah blah
it was also weird stuff at her uh
the day of the funeral we went back to
the house everyone's crying and stuff
and i went outside
and i was like i can't believe i i i
hope you're okay and i looked up dude
there was this
it was clear there was a freaking
rainbow in a circle
directly above her house so i went in
i'm like you guys gotta look at it we
all look it was
it was just wacky mo now of course other
people like well yeah because on those
particular days
right there's particles and that's why
in the science set like yeah well i
don't kill my moment
yeah for you it's that for me it's
something else yeah for me it's a little
bit of magic it's a [ __ ] loose care
bear out there
i don't know i don't know it's for me
something else bro take it easy yeah uh
i'm not shoving on you i'm just telling
you how i felt
like giving you a book and going right
here don't kill my magic
a lot of people want to kill your
[ __ ] magic i want to get magic
because they got none
they got none bro i'll tell you what it
was so scary when young people died man
well now i forgot where we're going with
this no go the one i interrupted you no
no
what what the hell was i even talking
about why was i saying this i don't know
bro you were talking was she your first
kiss you think that girl no i didn't
kiss her you didn't
never kissed wow just friends huh we
were deep friends and
oh powerful on the other side i don't
know where i was going but i'll tell you
it's perception you know when my dad
died that was the toughest
uh loss for me and after he died
i'm sitting this is crazy this is and
these are stories like i was afraid to
tell but i was like you know what it
happened what am i
i'm in my living room
would you you know those cries when
you're like
your mouth is open yeah it's almost like
primordial yeah it's pr i call it the
primal cry
and um i'm you know i pray like duh you
know what
what happens i don't know what happens
you know my wife thinks you'll see jesus
or whatever
i don't know who the hell knows
so i'm just asking like do you feel it
like d is it an energy do we become a a
plant like what what ha or just is it
nothingness are we in space
or we have fault like what happens yeah
and i'm going i wish i could just
feel his energy dude on my kids lives
hope they
die from lying i start here
and it's non-stop and i look in the and
there's this freaking bird
flying into the windows you think
anything like this he's weak
and i'm looking at him and you look like
your dad
he looked like that but i sit there then
i'm going
like dad like this is just like what's
going on dude
so i talked myself out of it this is too
weird this is crazy
every time i walk away thing we do it
again this
this bird for a year and a half
every day would start in the room where
my dad died
right and then he'd go around the house
and go to that same window every day
it was a cardinal now people now people
like you know
cardinals angel and uh
migration pattern they do yeah and but
then you got my father-in-law he's like
jesus christ it's a male bird he sees
his reflection he's trying to kill it
it's not your father you die we go in
the grave it's over
oh my god don't kill it man don't kill
it so now this thing becomes a joke
it really becomes a joke because um you
know the kids would start talking to the
grandpa grandpa's here it's weekend you
can't be knocking on the windows 6 30 in
the morning
i want to sleep on the weekend not cool
yeah
and then this is but this is the weird
part
this is weird this thing lasted
it showed up in october made a whole
year through october
all the way the following march it's
still going my wife and i and the kids
would go to turks and caicos and we go
there for vacation we'll see him
and that's a little bit of money i uh
not like a lot
i've done it right yeah i've done all
right um
i'm done all right so all my money
is is it's not in my bank it's in my
kids heads
right from private schools and it's in
africa and australia
and it's all over the place yeah it's
underwater scuba diving
whale sharks it's everywhere
they're like dad we're broken you show
them a picture of them on [ __ ]
kilimanjaro base camp
here's another 100k
that that zebra was worth every
100k cost
so so yeah that d
minus my kid gets in private school
that's my house on the beach right there
bang
um so with the which is why jim brewer's
on the comedy club tour
i wasn't thinking long term no
salary for a year how much money we got
left
oh my god start [ __ ] comedy clubs are
you sure
yes yeah yeah how much for a show uh two
dollars
bucket um [ __ ] schneider just did 14
shows here last week i saw that that's
crazy i saw all right so let me finish
and i want to talk about schneider
turkey caicos primal crime
bro i on my kids lives this is weird
i i go you know what and a mother i
talked just like that i went you know
what
i've been holding on to you too long
this is this is wrong for me to hold on
to you
this is what not i'm letting you go i'm
so sorry
that i've been crying like this i'm so
sorry i'm always sad when i think of you
from now on i'm just gonna i'm gonna
laugh my ass off i don't think he
because he was
funny my dad was dark funny
and sexually everything was a sex joke
yeah everything
oh yeah non-stop you know we'd my mom
would try to go to uh
if we go to a wedding which he hated
yeah hated church so the myth the priest
was like oh my god
yeah with no pants on jim
he just wants your money this [ __ ]
he was he just wants some money and some
kid titty you know
throwing him under the bus bro i would
bring him by snl and he you went through
my embarrassment you weren't talking
embarrassing
i'm surprised paul abdul hasn't coming
out of the woodwork and try to sue me
because of my dad's actions
i will never forget never forget
my dad once he got comfortable paul
abdul's sitting on his lap
and he turns around and he's gone he's
looking at me he's like
can you handle this yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna
she's like i love him because you want
to play puppy the one dad
no no not the puppy
and what is it and she's like what's the
puppy i'm like no no please not cool
you gotta remember he's 80 something
years old he's like no i want to hear it
because that's when i sniff your ass and
you just growl
[Music]
so just to let you know yeah he was a
wild guy he's waves in the jungle for
three years
yeah i'd smell anybody's ass if i'm in a
jungle for [ __ ] three years dude
breaks down for an hour i'll [ __ ]
smell it you just growl
that's old school i used to have cocaine
to do that but the military i think was
cocaine just into a lot of people's
systems it was just this
you know when they went through some
real wars it just made whatever like
let's just do whatever
you know my dad would always say world
war ii i said what was because
he would not talk about whatsoever and
whenever i really pride him he'd go
thank god for the hillbillies
like why because they knew how to make
alcohol
anything they make i don't know anything
i give them a foot they know how to make
alcohol at
yeah really and you just don't even
think about things like that
like someone one of these rednecks knows
how to make booze
yeah hey give me four leaves on a
coconut we're gonna be hammered on
thursday
we're gonna get through this um
so i let them go all right
and so you really had almost like a like
i'm letting it speed up i'm letting you
go
holy spirit got held on to too long yeah
okay and so
now i'm testing myself i'm looking at
old people because if i saw someone
in a wheelchair i'd start sobbing yeah
if i saw if i saw
old people so now i'm purposely looking
for old people and i'm okay
now i'm starting to to laugh
and it's it's working so we go home
and we're unpacking the car and my
swear to god dude i'm i have nothing to
sell here
i'm just telling you what happened we go
in the house
and my father-in-law goes
hey uh you know the kitty lit is done
feather cassie is but that
the bird's gone everyone knew the bird
the bird's gone
gulemi's gone ah middle week he just
stopped coming around
and i i
sat down like this and i started
laughing because what so fine went
you don't understand
i let my dad go you don't think that's
weird
that this bird every day
is showed up when i asked and he goes oh
for christ's sake and my greats
jesus christ jimmy the hell is wrong
with you you mean my daughter's getting
into you stop with that
[ __ ] no god no cheese we just die and a
bird comes and go you have nothing to do
with your father
but that's the power of
it's it's perception it's uh right it's
not to be debated that's
my that's why i think a lot of people
start losing
you're like oh it's supposed to be even
my wife will go well it's not
hey don't don't i don't care what it
says here i mean i care and all that but
i'm just telling you what i did and this
happened that's my own thought my own
feeling yeah the magic sometimes it's
it's easier for people to kill the magic
man
it's easy for all the the words and the
literature and all the extra information
i got a story is we talking this guy um
what am i too long man
you're good man i'll tell you a story
jim so i'm down in orange county and
they used to have a church there and
they ended up
stealing a lot of people's money and
whatever but before that yeah but before
that that's
crazy dude i knew in the [ __ ] when
the guy came out in like
six robes on a [ __ ] like golden thing
and bro i remember i went to their
church service once
they had real camels
uh real you know they had real
like illegal aliens they had real slaves
at the manger like this i'm like this is
a lot you know what i'm saying like they
had to we're gonna
crush it this christmas eve hard
and we're gonna charge admission oh they
did and we're going to open up do you
know how hard it was to get these camels
dude one of the camels defecated on the
steps bro and people had to go up and
down it the whole night to get on the
stage
so anyway they busted this church but
one night one day i'm over there
i swear to god i'm trying to be quiet
crystal cathedral bring it up will you
well this is why sean shawn's almost
fine the reason why i'm laughing is my
wife goes to church
and he did the same thing three years
ago i think cam
and this church is small oh it's not a
big church bad idea and this thing
dropped the deuce right under the camel
it's sheep
yeah you can't camel a small church
here's crystal cathedral right here and
this is in
uh orange california and the the walls
would open that's big
oh this thing was huge and so yeah so in
the back there that's all glass and then
on the right if you know go back to that
picture if you don't mind sean
nope right there if we can zoom in on
that or get it bigger
yeah so on the right there where it's
kind of open that's actually the wall
opens
up and uh wow yeah the walls open like
that it's just the way it's built i mean
it was a nice
homeless people that's the man right
there robert oh yeah he's famous
bobby schuller yeah and his daughter i
think might have been a lesbian but
beautiful brian really talented i
thought
but um anyway so i'm sitting there
there's this lady sitting next to me
the the doors open up a butterfly comes
in
right comes in lands on this woman's
cheek she's probably about 85 maybe
lands on her cheek
thick makeup right can't move you know
and i'm sitting right next to her and
i've already been kind of just chatting
with her you know it's church you know
it's really
right you should yeah you say hey or
especially you see an older person
you look fantastic yeah oh you look
great yeah oh you're only 85 you know
wow you look silly you look 79 you look
78.
so pleased i met you yeah yeah yeah like
that yeah
oh wow you have soft hands you oh you
seem like you're gonna die soon things
like that you know
just things that go through your head
you got a good three months yeah yeah
it's going to be a good three yeah
you're gonna do fine she goes
i said oh ma'am i said there's a
butterfly on your cheek you know
and she goes oh that's my son he died in
a car accident
uh six years ago uh today
and every year today he comes
and visits me at church and i was like
it blew on bro i'm not even i gotta go
look at my phone i took pictures
me sitting there like this like and i
would just it blew my mind like she was
not concerned and it stayed there the
whole service and then
jetted out you know and i don't think
that that's like
elon musk you know doing early trial
[ __ ]
i believe that that's something i do too
it's just a piece of energy that was
just wanted to spend time with her
listen there there is energy i i think
about this sometimes like
you mean if we have a chemistry we're
talking there's an energy there
this is an energy yeah where's the
energy come from does it come from
somewhere higher is it do we create it
no one knows science can't create all
that stuff
you know here's a here's um i remember
you talking about seeing the long term
something that just taught me the long
term
i have a um you know my mom's side of
the family
it's four different men and we don't
know who the one
my one sister's dad ever was and your
mom she dated her she dated me a lot of
men yeah she started my parents are
different my dad
zero i mean he would tell me he's like
wow
we used to have a lot of turtle soup and
possum pie
and i thought he was kidding and i
realized he wasn't
yeah wow when i see all the brewers
together they're like remember paul
would make you go along the tracks jim
and if you didn't come with the right
amount of buckets now he's
five granted and he just whooped your
ass we felt so bad
you didn't get bread that night and i'm
like
what come on that didn't real now she
meet now he
he ends up with my mom who grew up in
greenwich village oh
fancy big fancy but then her world came
crashing down she lost her dad she lost
her husband while she had a kid and
today and her mom kicked her out
she must have so she spiraled out of
control
abusive horrible relationships like my
st
my step my step family side
horrifying just horrifying
where i came along like i my life kicks
ass
yeah um and so it did
it freaking kicked i didn't know any of
that we were blue collar but
we still was just amazing um
so damn where's that going with this man
see what happens are you starting
i started talking about that lady landed
the butterfly landing on the ladies
cheek at the thing
yeah and then you oh oh i know what's
gonna say
so the long term we were talking about
before because you don't know the long
plans or the grace in life
this is another crazy story let's do it
so my nephew
when nephew had a tough run mm-hmm the
black mixed or what was he
uh no dad dad left he was a heroin
addict
um and my sister my sister got arrested
she died uh 59 couple
same year my dad died um but she was a
great soul but
never got over the trauma so she was
your father
of just her life of her life of what her
dad did to her
so this is she was on the freight train
you know
whatever she was she's just trying to
kill the pain
but her kids her one son i went he's
gonna either be
dead or he's gonna be in prison
and she'd always say like jimbo he looks
up to you like a
but i i was i was 10 years old and him
like i can't
and and when i went after my dream we
lived in florida
i was petrified to leave him because his
nephew yeah
because i knew i was 22 he was 12 and
what's his name ronnie or something
steve oh steve o's yeah good and i went
he's you saw it coming cops started
coming
uh you know this one like he's broken
some places spray painted up
nelly angry yeah exactly oh yeah i feel
you bro
yeah the pants are down he's he's going
there
he's going there sure enough um
off to the off to the off to camp yeah
the bad camp the saint the saint local
state oh wow so he'd write me while i
was on snl
and i was shocked he was still alive and
i'd send him a little stuff of hope
time for him to get out now i'm in in
new jersey got a beautiful home my
wife's pregnant two kids
and we start going he's he can't go back
home he
he's gonna go right back in he's gonna
get worse at home he can't go back to
his environment so he's gotta come here
he's gotta come he's only a chance to do
it so we bring him here and you're
talking about a movie
yeah so he comes i'll never forget the
first thing he does or he gets
i sent a car to pick him up oh bad news
i said a car to figure out a car picks
he gets out of the car he's got a wife
beater
he's six foot four i saw him a little
pudgy teenager wow
and he's inked on one side of his body
gets out of the car
and he squats he's like what's up uncle
jim
and he lights a cigarette and he's
squatting on the curb like that
and my wife and i looked inside ah maybe
this is a bad decision
so long story short it becomes the
greatest story
of our lives it it it was a lot of
a lot of trial and error a lot of
problems a lot of time
but we we realized we had a lot of work
to do with him
was it hard to love him was it hard to
love him through all the mistakes and
stuff
no for us it was easy because all i did
was i kept reminding like listen to me
you don't understand nobody want like i
had such backlash you can't do this you
have kids
and and rightfully so i didn't tell
anyone in the neighborhood i just told
my family and they were
full-blown you can't do this yeah not
now
i said do you understand he's going to
be dead you know what it's not your
problem
yeah you got everything going for you
that's mom's problem yeah
and my wife and i are like i don't know
man
so we had him there and the thing that
broke him was
so i'd say like listen you don't
understand
all i get out of this is that you become
a good person
and you're able to do your own thing i
go if
if once i'm gone you're screwed
you need to learn just just basic life
and that was through some things he was
going through still hanging out with a
yo-yo
and he started getting he got pulled
over and he was like oh he caught me
like oh my god
of course they caught you because your
hat's backwards getting high
through an area that nobody under a
million dollars lives
and the cops got nothing to do like look
at this some [ __ ] with pinning windows
you don't live here dude you want to
step out of the car
it happened to me when i first met the
same it happens to everybody
of course so that's why
the kids broke them i'll never forget
this oh that's cute there's like a movie
man
and i always said i'd write it but i'm
like all right i would be a good movie
it would be
he's sitting at the kitchen table and
you got to see him he's redneck as hell
funny as you funny no we'll only
vacation with uncle stevo and his wife
and children now
that we don't want to vacation whenever
we have he we
lo they were so much love he's sitting
there one day
this big tub he starts crying at the
kitchen table
like what's what's magic i never had
this i had what
goose what omelets
you never had an omelet let me tell you
something i'm just checking no no but
the fact you say that he
after three weeks like i want to make
you a meal swear to god
he made a prison meal he said i need sh
he ne
he said they need cheese cheese dip
cheese snips
yeah yeah cheese nips the square cheese
yes yeah he needed them yeah he needed
cheese doodles
uh noodles and he would explain he's
like this was like
it would take months to get these
products this is a wedding cake
this was huge in the penitentiary
and it was we three bites one
but i just you know we're looking each
other like let him live this this is
this is a big
it's like the cat bringing a dead animal
this is for you
oh thank you i love how you just spread
the guts out
that was very kind to you meow to you
too
love you too thank you so he
and and he goes just this and he started
crying
and then the oldest daughter was five at
the time
and she she's like we love you uncle st
and the kids
melted him so life goes on he becomes an
amazing human being
gets married meets an amazing woman
have a child life is great suburbs blah
blah blah
now recently uh his father died
and whenever something goes on his
wife's like you got to come
he's going through something you got to
talk to him because i was the closest
thing i
i see him as like a brother he sees me
differently but it's 10 years
whatever so i go over the house his
father died now he didn't have a
relationship with his father
his father tried to come back but he was
too jesus
he didn't want to hang out have coffee
he was like you got to find jesus you
say stop doing that to me
just if you want to be dad be dad don't
i don't want stop putting this in my
face
you show me the cards i lose card
doesn't ask about my daughter
doesn't invest in my life it's just do
you find jesus i dude
i can't i can't and he and he kept
getting hurt going back and blah blah
so he had bad feelings because it ended
he didn't have closure his father died
during coven he had hepatitis c but
so i'm going over there dude i pull over
and i go we
what do you want me to say to him i got
i got to say something
because this kid's gonna be in turmoil
and you're just asking god yeah i said i
i said what do you want me to say to a
dude
it went boom i went holy crap i have a
relationship where i laugh i go
pro you are dude
i think i found god i would talk to you
a pretty good bit i think i'm like man
this is a cool holy crap i didn't see
that
so i go in there and i go listen
i know how you feel and we did small
talking i know how you feel about your
dad
all right we don't know let me expl
let me back up and tell you a quick
story so i tell him the story i'm about
to tell you
i go years ago when i was a little boy i
was about 10 years old
dad brought me to go see mom and dad we
go see johnny cash
get to see him a couple times we go to
ohio
um to visit this couple
and um there's this guy i met
and he said can i hang out with him for
the day i want to teach him how to
how to fish and blah blah and shoot a
gun
and my parents were cool i never shot a
gun i was scared to death
dad killed a bird he set up a can shot a
bird
and this is a stranger man you didn't
know what we're gonna get to that okay
and so he then took me fishing we were
driving i'll never forget he's playing
the stones he looks at me
he goes you like this i went yeah who is
this because it's satisfaction
it's is stones yeah i would i don't know
he's like you don't know
he couldn't comprehend i didn't know the
wrong stuff that happened to me at 19 i
didn't know him
wow but besides my kids my kids don't
know
good fellas like so
long story short we come home the day
before we go like can i show
can i show jimbo this album and he
he goes it's a comedy album stand-up
comedian this guy named steve martin
and he he he shows me the album and
steve martin let's get small
and he's got a fake you know the fake
nose and glasses and a balloon wrapped
around his head
so i'm instantly attracted because i'm
in 10th grade this is doofy
he puts it on and i was blown out of my
mind
that a guy could could just
he's telling jokes and he and he made a
record and he's in front of people
i never saw this before i saw lauren
hardy and i started laughing i saw these
tv shows but i never saw this this i saw
like people doing characters
and i'm listening i was blown at him and
i listened to it non-stop
i still know the album from beginning to
end steve martin let's get small
ramblin man remember ramblin i do the
whole album
changed my life it made me go into
comedy and go
get more into it and richard pyre and
then don rickles and george carlin and
boom i was off to the races
i go and that led to the life that i've
that led me to my journey right right
yes
and that journey there was a little seed
led me
to having a house and taking you in
having the opportunity to take you in i
never saw that guy much
after that i go but how great now look
at where your life is at
because i was able to give that to you
your daughter
and your wife i go that guy was your
father
i go so before you go i hated the rest
of life we don't know what the plan was
if he didn't do that for me and i hated
him for leaving my sister
but look at where we're at now wow but
that's
you have to be able to see that so that
was your sister's father
that was my sister's husband oh this was
stevo's father wow
so if he if that guy didn't give you
that album then maybe you don't end up
on the track you're on
absolutely not man that's powerful man
that's a heroin addict that's what he
was the dad was apparently he left he
was a heroin addict he's a drug addict
he might have had some mob ties because
my sister loved talking about that
well it's funny it's interesting about
laughter man it's like sometimes
somebody even if they can't maybe make
you laugh themselves or whatever they
want to just share something with you
that maybe
that makes them feel good you know it
happened to me with jerry clower a man
my best friend his dad this is in
mississippi they lived in
and he said to me one day said man you
have to listen to this and he put it on
in the car and it was got jerry clower
from
yazoo city mississippi and he's uh he
was a famous comedian for a long time
yeah
and he ended up doing it being a
preacher at the end of his life and then
he passed away
but he told these stories and i just had
never
you know he he said he always said he
didn't do jokes he said i it's stories
made
funny or i tell stories funny that's
what he said i tell stories funny that's
right but man he was but if ever since
he's dead gave me that i would have
never
yeah right nothing never my mind that
was the game changer and and
it didn't even change my life then i
mean it helped then me get into comedy
but i didn't come back to jerry clower
till about maybe four years ago
and that even changed my comedy
perception and career
and the way i perform and the way that i
want to reach people and
yeah man it's wild right it's a wild
ride it's
interesting how one little thing can
yeah it's about how do you what where do
those seeds how do you find that seed
a lot of times somebody needs to show it
to you by hand too whatever it is like
advertisements help and the computer
helps and that sort of thing but
if you can lead somebody like you take
somebody to a hockey game then you were
like holy [ __ ] now i love hockey you
know like that's what happened to me
somebody has to take you somebody yes
you almost need a
a sherpa you need that you need that
yeah that little push whatever and i
would see that
be on the road and and i remember the
first
time going the road was a loose spooky
little exciting
but i was young and i remember just
little
moments where you think it's something
or you might
and i just remember you know i i my
first road gig was cincinnati ohio and
who'd you open for do you remember
or was this when you were headlining no
i was the opener it was ray combs
club in cincinnati and
all i remember is i was so excited
because the headliner just won
star search yes wow the hundred thousand
dollars he won
oh my god was his name that was the show
though wasn't it at a certain point
uh it was but yeah i don't even know
why i brought him up but i'll tell you
the story so the
so i met you once before and this was in
so i was on a show called road rules
right it was like a reality television
show do you remember a show like kind of
remember that people playing games and
stuff and they used to have a show
called real worlds and
people was mtv it was mtv yeah so i
remember road rules
this is 19 this is 2002.
wow so this is in my half-baked touring
bus full-blown yeah i mean yeah it was
hardcore fat i was fat i don't i you
know what i
actually now that you say you had a
perfect look of a stoner like you really
had a perfect center look oh but here's
what happens so i'm waiting outside i'm
in florida i'm waiting outside
for my girlfriend she's coming she's
flying in to visit me right we have a
couple day break and we're in fort
lauderdale
and they put us up at a decent hotel and
we're excited and i'm
22 or something on him i'm gonna be on
him i'm doing fine you know i'm excited
i'm
also a weirdo but i'm i'm cool i'm
waiting outside for my girlfriend
and you come walking up right it's not
it's midnight she got in on the last
flight on southwest
and where is this this is in fort
lauderdale but where
at a hotel hotel i remember okay and it
had one of those elevators inside where
it was like you could
you could see out of the elevator when
you're going up so you can see the lobby
and stuff you know really okay
really cool all right so you come
walking up and i'm like holy [ __ ] you're
jim brewer
and you're like yeah man and uh i was
he's like what's going on i was like oh
nothing i'm here i'm working on this
mtv show it's called road rules you're
like oh i know that show it's like
you're like what are you guys doing just
running around hitting elephants in the
nuts
right that's what you said which is so
great that is something i used to say
all the did you really know why yes well
here's the crazy part
then in sandals you proceeded to act out
hitting an elephant yes you would jump
up and act like you were hitting
elephant nuts
dude and nobody else was around so there
was nobody that could believe this
and you didn't have camera phones and so
i'm like um would you wait for my
girlfriend you want to come upstairs and
smoke man and i was like
holy [ __ ] dude i just got invited to go
smoking
but if if she if she would have got
there our relationship wasn't if i was
high
it would have been i would have been a
mess that
i think i remember because i remember
acting out the whole doing elephant
noise
bro you did it like six or seven times
and it was just
the first time it was good yes and try
to reach and hit it yeah
and in sandals it was just like how is
this guy even trying this
bro and it was so crazy to me this is
before i was a comedian or even got into
comedy and that's why i love once i was
out of it i love
i did that was the me i loved everyone i
was surprised
i felt suppressed of those years
of just not trusting anyone everyone was
out to get you in the bat everyone was
talking behind your back everyone's
trying to get your fight i was
it was it was hard it was the worst well
do you feel like you're a trusting
person
me yeah very probably too much right
that's just trust everyone right out of
the bat
right right out of the gate because
there's no reason not to
um but i i literally go off the energy
and i really look into the eyes and if i
feel you're just
slightly off like that i know
right just not today yeah not today bro
dude i trust you
how long i've been on here i don't know
maybe two hours and i went deep i went i
went far
yeah i was up to here wow i'm going here
huh
this is heavy
we're hitting elephant nuts yeah this is
so crazy man it just that was such a
moment
and it's so funny i didn't know uh like
i didn't know that you know
we'd be sitting here now but yeah that
was such a like it was just so crazy you
were so
funny man wasn't it such a fun thing
being funny when you were young
were you funny when you were young like
were you funny in high school with your
buddies and stuff
i was dude that was the f to me there's
no other like
you can do specials and like do theaters
and do like
but man being funny with your [ __ ]
buddies in a group
when nobody will ever be able to
replicate the moment and you're just
like sewing this [ __ ] tapestry that's
just retarding you don't even know you
have needles in your hands
and you're just oh god i love that
greatest
high and gift of life yeah and i i i
high school was the best dude we had so
in our high school we had the first
black kid that ever wanted to be white
right wig because they ended up using
term wiggles but
they'd never seen it before in our area
right they'd never so they thought he
was mentally handicapped right this kid
brian st
pierre so they put him in the learning
disabled classes right and he just had
like a starter jacket and was like a
larry johnson fan
right like he just listened to like you
know bell biv devo he was just the first
white kid that wanted to be black
they'd just never seen he was like that
was rappaport i remember that
we had one that was doing breakdancing
everybody had one right and they didn't
know
but in our town that was a learning
disability i guess
my tattoos so they put him in there they
put him in the
learning disabled classes you had kids
in wheelchairs kids with down syndrome
kids with
you know like you know kids at home he's
doing this come on girl you understand
he's doing that
we had like but i remember just i
remember being in middle school
and it was so much fun bro junior high
and [ __ ]
those those times they i think they prep
you for the rest of your life to
laugh that hard to the camaraderie
yes the lifting each other up no matter
how bad it got
we'd you break one another breaking
each other to the point where you let
your guard down i
still live for that i live
to hang out uh close doors yeah
laugh our ass we go as far and wide as
we want as
funny as we want as dark as we
want there's just no judging there's
nothing better than
full-blown trust in those moments yeah
ah do you want who made you laugh who's
one that's really gotten you over the
years that really makes you laugh
comedian yeah or has in the day we
talked about rob schneider a little bit
oh yeah he's so talented at going in he
told his mother just passed when he was
going
into all these stories about her life
but then while he's telling him he
starts
acting out some of the characters and it
wasn't like a bit he was doing he was
just talking
about yeah he's talking oh man some of
it was so good
he you know it's really weird i
i was on a radio i would do radio years
ago
and i always rob was always one of my
favorites
and um he
came on the radio and i
he didn't want to be there he was in a
bad mood yeah
and happened it was a long time ago and
so i always thought from that moment
like oh man you don't like me
yeah you don't like me
and so there's still times when i feel
like going
because i l i follow him yeah i like
what he says
yeah me too i like i like what he puts
out there yeah
and there's so many times i feel like
going hey man i don't love you
you know i i really think you're cool i
mean i don't know if you don't like me i
don't know why you don't like me
do you think that we take things i take
things if somebody doesn't give me a
certain vibe
i i it then lands on me that they don't
like me but me too
i think it's very pretty that is yeah
why do you think that is cause you know
you know you know what that they don't
you mean yeah or they just
it's it's a uh but they don't it's
they're not thinking of it that far
we're
yeah you're right that far you're right
or maybe it's just like you're below
them like i took it as
it was so long ago this is right i'm
just thinking i guess generally like
when i
i notice that a lot for myself if
something happens even in a moment
it might mean nothing to them yeah this
thing with rob with me had to be 14
15 years ago yeah and he's probably
seven and he's probably doing morning
radio and doesn't want to do it he was
natalie yeah and then susan's over i'm
like is this his 40th
freaking interview you had him doing
non-stop he's done
he's done he's tired of saying the same
thing and uh it was
we take things personally though that's
what's interesting i was like oh man
i don't this whole plan like we're gonna
be hanging out
we're gonna be hanging out i'm gonna be
in a hot air balloon we're gonna
we're gonna have you ever been in africa
yeah dude you're gonna go to safari it's
pretty cool
yeah we're gonna go to the one of those
massage parlors one of the real good
ones if you have these ones where they
blow dart you in the neck right when you
go
in there's nothing better yeah you wake
up in [ __ ] time
you try to fight passing out you know
it's coming you see the other guys kind
of like no
no he makes he merely makes me laugh
spade makes me laugh mcdonald makes me
laugh i know everybody you
you norm makes me laugh dude
hold on i'll do that thing about norm so
he did this thing one time
he gets up he goes from one room into
another room right he stops at the
doorway and he's like
what is this what is like a
what is this he's like banging on the
door like just the doorway he's like
what is like a portal to like another
what is this and his ass he's literally
asking the people in the room right
what do what what do you call this thing
it's like a like a portal to
whatever how do you just go through
where am i and he was just talking about
a doorway but it was
so he makes anything funny yeah i
remember
it was me him he came it was
i think he was doing a show with spade
in irvine and uh i went to go watch
and he came we went we went like by the
dumpster afterwards
and it was me him i wonder what you're
talking about outside yeah that little
outside area where you park
yes yeah and i don't know if it was
there was one other person i don't
remember who's there so
he's saying are you stoned oh and not
man i stopped because what
jesus christ [ __ ] guy from heaven
can't [ __ ] his dumb again hi
[ __ ] you dino he was so angry till i
didn't want to get high
he was so pissed he was genuinely pissed
the [ __ ] is that who's the [ __ ]
brewery [ __ ] hey
jesus christ the [ __ ] his words are
you sure you again
jesus christ bro what the [ __ ] he was so
you judge me now and
no no i just i
stopped for a while man that's awesome i
did everything
i smoked as much as i could i beat the
[ __ ] out of marijuana
yeah it's hard yeah i think you won one
hit
i was crushing it i'm meeting i'm
meeting vaughn years before
talking about punching elephants in the
nuts been there done that
i did it yeah dude he uh
one time i had to open up for him and
this is at a casino we're doing like a
casino gig
in shawnee oklahoma and
cherokee creek casino i think and it
could have i don't know this cool lady
that i think maybe tried to make love to
somebody but
she also helped us get the gig and um
norm was [ __ ] up i think that when he
went on he went on after me like i don't
think he
i don't even think for the first seven
minutes i don't even think he said
anything right but the crazy part was
the next day um we were at
there was like a we had to play cards
too the next day you'd like be there for
the weekend
you know so we go to the card tables and
norm's like man there's a lot of
a lot of good [ __ ] in here and i don't
know him really well so i'm thinking i'm
looking around this room bro there is
zero attractive women right they're zero
attractive men okay
so it's not even if you wanted something
it's a scene there's nothing yeah it's a
casino and it's a it's a
gambling game it's poker yeah five card
poker you know so
and i'm just thinking well i guess i
just agree with him you know he's
getting older and you know maybe he has
a different perception of what's
attractive
i'm like yeah man they're sure he goes
[ __ ] no there isn't like he had played
me you know like
he's like this is the ugliest batch of
people i've ever seen
i was just talking about him the other
night now i was there
for one of the greatest norm moments in
comedy history
i think he he was kinked he was kicked
out of nebraska
that sounds realistic um and i you can
maybe look it up later
versus norman mcdonald was kicked out of
the state by the governor
and he went on he went on letterman
to talk about it uh and i want to say it
was like 1996
because i just finished my first year
snl was 95 so it was the summer of 96
and i remember going on tour there you
go you saw it go down
yeah kicked out of iowa that's me
talking about it okay
uh but anyway should we look on a video
or should we no no don't look at that i
want to see the
real there has to be a headline how nor
mcdonald got kicked out of iowa
yes okay gazette there you go
okay all right so
many were disgusted some were delighted
so he's supposed to know you understand
something okay
he his first time me touring with a star
okay we go to the airport and people
like oh my god you're norm mcdonald
wow this is everywhere we went oh my god
you're nor mcdonald
we show up at the university he's like
yeah i gotta go
golfing with the [ __ ] governor they
made me a [ __ ]
golf [ __ ] governor yeah
he's with a governor this is huge
who gets to say that so i'm
i'm it's me daryl hammond and him and
you you
all both you guys went we're all we're
on the gig
okay okay we're going out he's telling
us yes
and so uh we get to the gig
and is packed
and they go now listen there's kids here
and there's students and alum
and the dean and all these people here
so that's the worst
they're like yeah clean i get it no
worries i go we're in sunny lake i guess
that's why we got you guys because
you're used to live tv pull up
so daryl goes up first does his 20
minutes
does impressions does his comedy
hilarious i go up
do my 20 feel great crush it
norm goes up i'm not even exaggerating
the first thing he says he goes out he
goes
look i'm preparing i'm like this is
going to launch my crew are you kidding
me
this is going to be huge i'm going to be
off he goes
[ __ ] where the [ __ ] at me the first
person even curse
all right oh [ __ ] he cursed he goes so
if you're gay would you rather be the
ass guy
or the dick guy
this is what he starts off with so
i go i go daryl you got to come see this
and he's going
and he won't stop he's there because if
you're depressed maybe you're the
ass guy why do you want to be there
he's going off people are grabbing their
kids running up the aisle they're i mean
i never saw a place clear out like a
fire alarm was going off
but the college students were staying
and they were
howling with laughter and he
one thing and then in the middle after
about 15 minutes he goes
jesus christ what are you [ __ ]
airplane jokes
he went [ __ ] 7-11 joe said jesus
christ
[ __ ] out of here so the next day
in the paper usa today or the cassette
like norma mcdonald's out wow governor
wants him
out of this state governor get out of my
state but to witness that
was i i have so many norm moments in my
life
my my first press conference with norm
was
they prepped us into like you know is he
gonna speak and
it's just some it's live bbc
and he's a bigger star than you so you
have to sit there and kind of pay you
have to be
it was him and spade right next to him
you have to be second fiddle at the
moment or were you
yeah man i just got i'm i'm i'm the new
kid on the block we're all a new cast
it's all new cast except for spade tim
meadows
and north macdonald wow and we're like
whoa and even looking at norman spade i
was like
oh these guys are star like this is huge
yeah
i'm really looking off to them and uh
the press conference go and i dropped
the ball right out of the bat right out
of the bat
um they asked me the lor the head of nbc
who fought for me to be there
goes uh jim what was it like growing up
watching snl and now you're here you're
from new york and now a fellow new
yorker
i said i didn't watch snl growing up
well you can hear i was like oh
i saw i went oh that was
spade went so he said
and i knew right away like oh man that
was really bad
that was bad and so he goes like well i
i i wasn't allowed to because i was
young and he goes
what about when you were oh he's trying
to prep me he goes surely when you got
older and and you were allowed to watch
it
and i went i was out on saturdays i
wasn't watching tv
and and norm's like
you're gonna like you you're gonna like
you yeah this guy is that guy
and he's smoking he's smoking
and marcy klein he's just going no put
out the cigarette
i'm not done this guy's gonna get fired
so i think i'm gonna get fired because i
saw lauren michael's face he was pissed
so you sitting there super nervous at
this point do i swear in my life in my
kid's lives i thought i was gonna get
fired
because i just basically said i don't
watch sunday live yeah and i never did
and yeah which is not not a good answer
the message
in front of the press yeah and i didn't
say it in a mean manner
but i could just tell the boss man was
like
uh so oh jesus lord so now i'm sitting
there thinking i'm gonna get fired
swear to god and i'm just like oh my god
even get i don't even make it the first
episode i'm gonna let me go this is
what's going on my head
the has there has to be a video this
press conference
in the black market somewhere i i've
looked for it never found it
it's the 1995 press conference and
and so they asked norm they go norm
you tim meadows david spade
you've been here you you know the frat
house everyone knows
snl is a frat house what kind of what
kind of practical jokes you got lined up
for these new cast members
and i swear to you i went
i'm not even going to be part of the the
frat house or the practical jokes
and norm goes
he first always annoyed he goes
practical
is that what you jokes what kind of
practicum is just uh
first we were thinking about anal rape
you know like hey hey
yeah take your going to italy rape you
welcome to standing line we're going oh
[ __ ]
he's going to get fired too you can't
say you know rape you're from the
president
he said anal rape just suddenly you're
like i'm back in it i'm in it
i'm good i'm good and i went up to him
after i went nori's like dana again you
know he has a [ __ ] bro
in fact you know he's [ __ ] these guys
and i realized he would pitch at the
pitch meeting he just didn't care
he didn't care and i learned so much
from him
just clearly he saw a lot and he's been
there forever like he would
i remember he gave he got he gathered
the new cast up he's a geek guy sporting
god
yeah don't write me any of your gay
[Laughter]
[Music]
sketches
but don't put me in your gay little
i swear to god man i also traumatized
him we were
we would play football in the hallway
because he was very competitive
he's always betting it was a very tiny
hallway maybe as wide as this
maybe and uh he's like come on baby
thank you i'm playing
three in the morning oh [ __ ] it come on
[ __ ] playing football meet you colin
quinn
and [ __ ] uh justin justin you [ __ ]
[ __ ] the phone calls no one's calling
three in the morning
get in the [ __ ] ball let's go so he
would cheat would piss me off because
i'm competitive
and i'll never forget he keeps cheating
and cheating and
now i'm pissed how's he cheating it's
like a hallway it's like a hospital
hallway wait but he [ __ ] cheat he's a
cheater
yeah right so oh yeah he has a cheater i
had
boots on so i had i had work boots on
yeah yeah because yeah you use those to
write in yeah so is he running [ __ ]
work boots on stone
oh the ink's heavy yeah yeah yeah so now
he he he cheat
i caught the ball and then he he grabbed
it
and pulled it from me he's like hey
fumbled and he starts running the other
way i'll never forget i
[ __ ] kicked him as he's running in
his
in his calf on pow
and he goes
jesus christ bro why did you [ __ ]
kick me in my [ __ ] calf
that's because you're cheating so you
[ __ ] kick me
ah jesus christ and all he did
all week he like [ __ ] really [ __ ]
kick me in my calf
because i took the [ __ ] ball jesus
christ bro
and spade just in the distance like hey
yeah so those in a moment
i absolutely i i loved more that stuff
you know all of it was worth it all of
it was worth it one needy but it was all
worth it
god so damn i'm exhausted yeah we'll
finish up man
i could talk for hours we'll chat we'll
chat another another night
i'm coming to the show tonight i'm gonna
come watch which one
not sure which one's better you think
probably
well the second one i'll prob i'm looser
and i'll go
longer the first one i'll come second
one though because um
yeah time restraint i'm yeah yeah it's
still early
and a lot of my bits are long
so i i constantly go okay so i'm
40 minutes in uh
should i do this one or that so it's i
think a little bit more in the first
shows
where lesson excuse me last night is not
thinking
second shows it's no thinking just like
yeah
if i feel like going this way i go this
way that way that way
did it change is his comedy changed for
you in different times like were there
times where you got to like uh
okay this was my set and then you
started to change at a per as a person
because this one thing i'm noticing for
myself like
sometimes i'm trying to maybe still be a
person that
did a set from previous in my life but
i'm
i'm being i'm different as a human yeah
and it's scary
to think will i still be able to be
funny as this person that's growing and
getting different
than i was as this person who was it's
scary but you will be
you've you've long passed that part yeah
you've learned to grow
you've learned to grow as a person you
you've learned to grow as an
entertainer you learn to grow
you learn you've you've created your
audience and you're following
and you will make them grow up with you
in every direction oh wow
and that's what i discovered my biggest
fear was
i'm a family guy i'm getting really
exhausted trying to appeal
to something i'm not totally yeah and at
that time yeah i was kind of
stoner i was i loved the yeah man
life's good ha ha and it was great
but once i had kids i started moving
along like i'm not this guy
and i'm tired i i can't hold on to
pretend to be in this person for
so much longer and then as i grew it was
around 2008
so i was just like listen i'm going on a
ride if you guys want to come along come
along but i'm never going to be
i can't be what i was 5 10 15 years ago
because i'm not
yeah i'm letting you no one is i'm
letting you go huh i gotta let you go
i loved you for being there but we're
moving along am i i have to say
the audience grew to to a point where i
had
no and not only did they grow
you created everyone you want to be with
wow
and that's what you're going to do and
that's what you do do wow that's
fascinating to hear that
yeah dorfman at um at the club says this
is the funniest that he's ever seen you
he said oh i feel because i just he said
that the other day
i'm really good in at life i'm really
good at
what what what today said that you know
we i saw him the other night
i stopped by to see schneiderlin oh so
he didn't even see me last night
no he hadn't seen you he just said from
the last time he just he just talked
about your career a little bit
and then yeah i got better yeah he was
telling me that too so he i said yeah
because i i'm not trying anymore i
know i'm funny yeah i know i'm gonna
entertain you
i'm very comfortable going in certain
directions even if i go too heavy i know
i'm going to come back and smack you
with something else
yeah there's some material i'm doing now
that i'm
bored with and i want to do a lot
i'll come out and go i'm going to do the
first half hour just winging it
but then i'll see they're really stoked
and i'll go ah yeah there's that thing
in your head
i don't want to i don't know if this is
the crowd to take the chance with i
don't want to waste
there like this and the last thing i
want to do is bring them here
and then bring them back and so yeah
it's a constant mind game but my my show
both every show is different cool
well i'll be out there tonight um and uh
thanks so much for hanging out bro my
god this was such a good time
i could have talked forever and ever i
appreciate you giving me that
opportunity
and giving me that trust and and uh
this whole feeling it's good energy man
thanks man yeah it's exciting to hear
and just to learn and just
i think i look at other comedians and
yeah just even hearing that i'll be okay
and that this is a performance this is a
human
you know i think there's a level of that
that you know especially getting
involved in hollywood and this just all
the whole journey it's like
well i'll be okay as a human you know
you'll be fine you're you already are
yeah you're already there amen bro
thanks man
brother beast good now i'm just floating
on the breeze and i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
and these rails that i've been riding on
they want something